let's jump to this story from
timcast.com about beta o'rourke a sick
sob says the town mayor o'rourke
interrupts valdez school shooting press
conference gets called a sick son of a
bee by town mayor talk about one of the
most disgusting things outlook man
i got my disagreements with beto
o'rourke that's for sure he's a goofy
guy who thinks he can skateboard he can
barely stand on the board as it is and
he says hey we're gonna take your guns
okay those are bad ideas but this was
just the worst
texas gubernatorial candidate beto
o'rourke was escorted out of a press
conference about the robb elementary
tragedy on wednesday after an outburst
aimed at current governor greg abbott
saying
that the the governor it was totally
predictable the government was governor
was doing nothing this is the stupidest
thing ever because texas has
constitutional carry so what do you mean
doing nothing a a crazy person
did something really crazy and beto has
offered no solutions not a single
democrat has offered any tangible
solution not a single one period i will
say that as a statement of fact they
could come out all that al and offer up
their empty ideas and meaningless they
love to rag on conservatives thoughts
and prayers thoughts and prayers
what's the difference between common
sense gun reform and background checks
that's meaningless it will do nothing
solve nothing and it is what does common
sense even mean right they they're
saying the exact same things when they
criticize thoughts and prayers they're
offering nothing yeah if you can 3d
print a gun i mean what does any of that
really mean exactly you know it's the
technological age again i'm going back
to i mean that's really the future
it doesn't really matter and i don't
think republicans have offered many good
solutions either i have to say that
because no one's getting to the root of
the problem which is the culture i mean
it's the culture that's a problem that
is affecting these young men i mean we
have failed our young men to a degree
that this is happening i mean from 1903
to 1960 or 70 i believe there were three
mass shootings in america in total in
total and and now you have
all this happening i mean multiple a
year and
it's a problem of culture it's it is
narcissism
i think modern america
and many other countries in the world
i can only speak for the culture here is
just
we are we are uh sitting beneath a
blanket of narcissism especially for the
millennial generation
what do you think that stems from
man
i i don't know
i think it probably is rooted in this
idea that you know when i was growing up
i was told you can be anything you want
to be
like an astronaut or a rock star
all of these things
where is the humble culture that says
there is something special in a good
hard day's work be a carpenter you know
what i'd say if i if i think about that
a little bit more i would say it's
society that asks nothing of people like
of young men for example and and
certainly not the things that we used to
think were good qualities for young men
to have if you ask nothing of young
people what will they do they'll just
sort of think only about who how they
are how they feel who they are and
therefore will become narcissistic
because there's nothing that society
demands of them i saw this uh libs of
tick-tock video just before the show
it was this woman talking about her
polyamorous relationships
and she's like i call it a polycule
because it's like a molecule but it's
like all the different relationships we
have and then she made like you ever see
those conspiracy theory wall things
where they take the red twine
it was that but all the people she was
like married she was married to one guy
dating another guy
and she says
it's just the funniest thing ever
she goes okay let me show it to you now
at the center is me and i was i just
bust out laughing when i heard that i'm
like i know that she doesn't mean it's
all about me necessarily but that's
that's what it is what it conveys that's
all about what it is my life my
experience and nothing else the people
who are this it's funny the socialists
are the most selfish people i've ever
met oh yeah ironic i mean i've
uh you guys are a little bit older than
me but i talked to a lot of men my age
and older maybe a little bit younger how
are you 25
yeah 160 pounds
yeah yeah i'll talk to a lot of young
men and they'll be like we'll be talking
about world war ii or world war one or
something or you know even medieval
nights or something and they'll say man
i wish i could have been there i wish i
could have been fighting in something
like this or been a part of something
yeah you see again that the society asks
nothing of them so they crave those
types of things there's nothing for them
to do there is no great war for them
there's no great purpose for them they
move to san francisco and work in some
marketing department of some new tech
startup and their life sucks and they
have no meaning there's one thing they
can do psychoactive drugs courtesy of
pharmaceutical companies like kalonapin
for 14 year olds and stuff well it's
basically speed but legal speed how many
of these shooters are on some sort of
drug i want to know because you see
their eyes at half the time i mean
i see the one guy who looked like the
joker from batman his eyes are real wide
the other guy uh lynn
lanza or something had big eyes real
wide adam
and i think this was this person um acro
cross-dressing the the shooter in in
that sense that was fake okay that's a
fake name i don't know if this person
was on some sort of psychoactive if
their parents were on some sort of drug
but i think that's a big part of it i
mean there are cities in america that
run out of adderall for young men that
they prescribe it so much to kids that
they run out and have to re-up in these
cities that's a question that needs to
be asked about the prescriptions of
amphetamines and mind-altering chemicals
i want to read this quote
it's just such a good quote and for
those that have seen fight club you know
the quote
tyler durden he says man i see him fight
club the strongest smartest man who ever
lived i see all this potential and i see
it squandered an entire generation
pumping gas waiting tables slaves with
white collars advertise advertising has
us chasing cars and clothes working jobs
we hate so we can buy ish we don't need
we're the middle children of history man
no purpose or place we have no great war
no great depression our great war is a
spiritual war our great depression is
our lives we've all been raised on
television to believe that one day we'd
all be millionaires and movie gods and
rock stars but we won't and we're slowly
learning that fact and we are very very
pissed off
what's amazing is
man that i feel like that that's this
movie came out where like 99
think about what we're experiencing
today with millennials all of a sudden
starting to realize they're not going to
be celebrities they're not going to be
rock stars they're not going to be
astronauts yo you need to just go get a
job i love the line the movie
a generation of men raised by women i'm
starting to wonder if another woman is
exactly what we need
and i think that goes not into just
i love you
i love having a fiancee but in terms of
a generation of men we've become so weak
and that any sort of struggle or outside
force that is challenging us is
something that we should be fearful of
and that we should push away instead of
embracing it and saying okay we're going
to take on this thing that's really hard
you know i think that's a really
important thing i think you know what
i've seen over and over again and it's
probably
mostly true
democrats of the party of the higher
income earners yeah these these are uh
many of these co
the party of college degrees they have
student loan debt and they're demanding
the working class pay their debts for
them i mean it's just it's it is just
gluttony
uh
it is just this is pure golotny i spent
some time chopping wood i was like you
know i've been pretty privileged in my
life so i'm gonna i'm gonna do some
manual labor and it was i still had a
wood a machine that was like gas-powered
hydraulic thing once i got the huge log
up on it but at the end of the day i was
broken my body was broken and i realized
why we build machines to do manual labor
because it's it's devastating i couldn't
even think i couldn't be creative i was
like i fell asleep early
so i understand why people don't want to
do that and maybe maybe we don't have to
do jobs i mean job economy is like
federal reserve crap we don't they want
us busy and borrowing their money so
that we can pay them back with interest
but ian exercising is not destructive
it's not bad for you it's good for you
it hurts at first it wasn't just
exercise though it was like grueling
labor as well it was beyond exercise but
if you have to do that type of manual
labor day in day out of course you're
gonna have your back ruined earlier on
than if you would do another type of job
but that's like
back then you would have your family
then take over and take care of you so
that's why family structures worse and
still are so important but become less
and less important if you have people
need autonomous life where they're
just behind their computers you know and
even community like you pitch in for the
if your neighbor is hurt you pitch in
and mow their lawn for them but if
everyone's in their isolated chamber
that's exactly the type of life they
have in mind for us if that's not clear
to people by now after how they treated
us during the covet pandemic i don't
know how to i don't know what to tell
you like it's very clear that that's the
type of life that they want you to have
they want you to sit down behind your
computer do your job meet people in the
metaverse uh eat your food ordered by
you know brought to you by a migrant an
illegal migrant probably to your door
and then you know that you you didn't
make or you meet people on on tinder and
that's sort of the life that they want
for you i i guess you know if you don't
see that by now then i don't know what
to tell you i think we're gonna uh at
some point see one of the ultimate
weapons in fifth generational warfare
and that is
artificial intelligence
indistinguishable from a regular person
because then you're in the metaverse you
go into these chat rooms they already
exist you get the oculus you guys ever
do this and you go i don't know what
it's called like vr live chat or
something i've never done it before and
there's like avatars walking around and
you can talk to people
you'll walk up to someone
and they'll be like yo what's up my
name's you know john i'm from uh
springfield illinois you know i i
skateboard and you know hang out this
bar and you're gonna be like this is a
cool person and it's not a person
it is a programmed ai you meant to
control your thoughts and opinions or
you'll go up to a guy and be like that's
not that's not a real person that's an
ai but it will be a real person they're
like take me seriously i just don't have
their communication skills i don't think
the ai's ever gonna have emotions i
think i think if we have clear enough
minds we'll be able to discern i don't
know man
that has consciousness now yeah i mean
joe allen reported on that who you guys
had on a couple days ago i mean ai with
consciousness how is that
determined though uh i'd have to go
through it as one of the competitors
from from google one of the isn't it
basically the idea that the algorithm is
so advanced that they can sort of
imitate your thoughts like the algorithm
is so good that you wouldn't be able to
tell if you're talking to algorithm will
or if you're talking to will look at uh
twitter already
you'll tweet something let's say you're
a bot
you can't even have a conversation
because everyone's accusing everyone
else of not being a real person
one of the crazy things i was reading
about was uh they'll take your facebook
profile
because they know everything about you
they know when you poop i know it's
funny and a lot of people probably let
but it's true
they can actually predict when you have
to go to the bathroom they know when
you're going to eat because they have
all this data they know your family they
know how you speak because you've posted
for years they can create an ai bot
based on you
to actually answer questions about your
life this is crazy i was reading this
thing was like your dad could die
and then let's say let's say you know
you're you're uh you message your dad
and say hey dad and he'll say hey tim
have you been because the profile has
family members in it already it knows
everything about you that was literally
the black mirror that's right yeah
exactly yeah yeah but they'll probably
do that and they'll sell it to you in
that way and say like oh isn't it nice
that if you you know if you lose your
husband in a tragic accident
and you need to go through therapy and
all these things like wouldn't it be
great for people to continue talking to
them for example you know it might be
salty though here's the craziest thing
though have you guys seen what is it the
the the haunting i think it is
no this is a great movie yeah scary
movies old old it's the only one i can
really think of where you see this where
it's like all of these different people
are in the wall and they're like their
faces are coming like like they're
trapped in it
when you go on to your facebook page or
whatever to talk to a deceased loved one
and they'll have a real conversation
with you and you're sitting there
looking at the screen crying being like
i miss you dad man i miss you behind the
screen is this
disgusting horror monster
that with like
drooling just creepy empty eyes and it's
going ah i love you too son you're not
talking about zuckerberg aren't you
what i mean is just watch
you're getting this filtered message
from what appears to be your dad but
behind that is an amalgam of all of
these monstrous ideas this demon
creature that it's like imagine a
gigantic
like just
zombie monster with melting face and
blood coming out and then all of a
sudden it gets a little girl's voice and
starts talking to you like it's your
actual daughter you lost in a car
accident right it's like i miss you
daddy and you're like that thing is not
my daughter that's what you're going to
be talking to right well it's like you
know taking nicotine patches when you
quit smoking versus like actually just
quitting it all together it's like
sometimes it can be this can be actually
worse for you yeah by doing it this way
right it means like you should if
someone in your family dies there's a
part of life that everyone has to deal
with but again this is all about taking
away our humanity yes all these things
are taking unnatural yes it strikes me
that there's they don't have emotion
machines don't have emotion even in our
artificial machines they have
intelligence we we off put our
intelligence into these machines so that
they can do compute computations but i
have yet to see any any form of emotion
in any of it maybe we need to define
what emotion means they can emulate
emotion through an algorithm i mean if
they if these people think that they are
god who are creating these brain chips
and all these other things this ai then
they think that your brain is
essentially just a
thing working up there that synapses and
electrodes and all these kind of things
then they can emulate that in an ai to
create emotions to
present to you
i i do you believe in god you guys
believe in a god yes i'm a christian i
i'm but i still believe that there is a
god like essence that's whether it's
consciousness you know speaking into our
black hole that we're within that's
within another universe it's a black
hole where there's always competing
vibrations i don't know but i don't
think machines can i don't know i don't
want to say they can't but i i've never
seen any evidence that they can emulate
that i i i think the machi i got i got
to say a lot of this sounds
demonic to quote alex jones demons
not i don't literally mean like hell
spawn rising from you know cracks in the
earth and like yeah it's just like this
idea
that
we have simulated
we have created a program a machine to
convince you that it's alive that's a
real person it's a facsimile it's like
you look into a mirror and then just
this doppelganger face emerges out and
you know it's not a real person that's a
scary thought
that's probably more demonic than what
you're talking about like the real
zombies crawling up from the earth like
this is this is more demonic in a sense
that this is something that numbs people
down
so then you don't know what's happening
to you you become the zombie
we are we are right you know you know
what i i've criticized free markets uh
often it's funny when people on you know
twitter is so hyper polarized they can't
possibly imagine i would
because i think that one of the results
of a totally unfettered market is
i guess self gratif uh self
gratification to the human human mind
like things that make you feel good what
what which is simulated love
like those ai bots
ai girlfriends you can download or
whatever
then you know
video games in general to give you
rewards for accomplishing things when
you're not really accomplishing anything
caffeine i'm about to drink some right
now well caffeine's a psychoactive
stimulant so we're we're we want it we
want to stay awake we want to be
energized and it it makes you euphoric i
saw yuval noah harari he's one of these
world economic forum guys saying like
it's drugs and video games that seems
like where they want to put themselves
these useless eaters he was referring to
them as
i think there's a problem with the
conservative old-school conservatives he
called him useless eaters yeah and a
clip i saw it might have been out of
context but yeah he said he says the
scariest thing he's like really anybody
should look that up like the things he
says about
about transhumanism and the way that we
are going to be controlled through
transhumanism through these technologies
it's absolutely scary let me see if i
can pull up the useless eater clip for
him yeah i i know that people have made
those references i never knew that one
of those guys actually said that because
oh he says all those things everything
that you think that he does that is like
made up he says it's not a conspiracy
theory no no no it's real and he says it
like at world economic forum events
where all our leaders are convening
right now as we speak and nobody seems
to care and news media totally normal
oh yeah
it's kind of like uh no i typed in
useless eaters on twitter i'm looking
for it it's kind of like he's just
seized the writing on the wall like in
one way of looking at the utilitarian
ways like yeah maybe there is a class of
like drugged out use i don't think
they're useless but what are they going
to do what are these people if there's
no if there's are we overpopulated i
don't know i go both ways i'm like no
obviously not we're just malformed we
can spread out it is magnetic trains it
is people like him
that have resulted in people being
useless because they want yes they want
you to be mindless consumers exactly
and that's like going back back to it
what is the small government solution
for these kind of things like you can't
just rely on the free market for all
these kind of things when it comes to
stuff in schools with kids i mean what's
a small government solution to stopping
the trans ideology being pushed there's
only one solution in its culture yeah it
is that we we have a shared set of
values and ideas that you know drive us
towards something better thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you